right okay here's the thing whenever I
make a new video recently okay I always
get these comments from people saying
that I have changed oh my god Charlie
you used to be so random whatever
happened to the Charlie randomness
charlie
oh my god Charlie used to be so random
you've changed man
you used to be different and I'm just
like I haven't changed right I'm pretty
sure that in my lifetime I have not
changed at all so where you people are
getting these ideas from is beyond me
I don't know what you people mean what
is Charlie randomness I don't I don't I
don't know what it I'm just confused
basically but I have an idea basically
basically basically what I'm gonna do
today is give you a concentrated dose of
Charlie randomness so if you're one of
those people who watches one of my
videos and things this isn't hilarious I
like it when he does random stuff watch
this video come back to this one and
hopefully you will be satisfied that is
the plan so here is your dosage of
Charlie randomness Johnny yes so charlie
yes so Tommy is so good hey Charlie
what's that there you're reading oh this
I'm just reading a book
hey are you reading my book upside down
why yes I am because I hey does anyone
wanna play Mario Kart Wii I sure do hey
here's my friend code let's play Mario
Kart Wii together hi I'm just gonna take
a phone call oh hey there's no one on
the phone have you ever noticed that I
have a very big mold here on the side of
my face hey let's play Nintendo I really
like playing Nintendo Wii but I don't
have a wrist strap because I am hardcore
you're quite pretty hey I'm gonna shouts
does anybody want a hug just a quick one
you feel better I bet you won't expected
this look at this the camera is at a
different angle oh my god
I am so random today one is going to me
okay I'm just gonna take off this sock
did you see that did you even see that
I'm pretty sure this is randomness but I
don't know I think there's a fine line
between random and completely and
utterly insane do you dare me to get an
ice-cream because I will oh my god it's
actually really really cold and that
kind of hurt my teeth I guess I've got
to finish this ice cream now so just
just give me a minute
Oh probably pepper on the mirror but I'm
always be out
that was a really nice ice cream
oh there are live naked people on TV
sorry what what's going on today that
ice cream has kind of settled me and I'm
not feeling as random as I was five
minutes ago so here comes a burp but I
hope that little dose of randomness was
concentrated enough for you and there's
another birth challenge Charlie videos
will come as soon as I have my head on
I've been doing a play for ages so now
that I've finished doing that play I'm
going to try it and make two videos a
week I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to stick to that but that is my goal and
if I manage to do that then you can give
me a cookie please and that's it goodbye